I call it 10 dimensions as 10 women, but
tee hmm
soba is composed of about 4 processes
. I have to finish those 4 processes early, but if it's too long
It runs out because there is no
gluten. It's a process of mixing water and powder. It's not just mixing
water, it's hard to mix powder and water.
[Music]
When you're young, athletics 100 meters  I'm doing a short distance, and the first is to touch the river
that gives
me energy, thinking about how to do it from them
, and touching it with my body.
The
work of feeling the state of the powder with your body
is the next work I'm saying, but that's why I hit the powder in the air
.
Then, it's the premise of the powder against gravity.
It starts to connect only by gravity.
Finally, motion wave is completely different from the first note vol game.
This time, I use all the balance for the whole body. Big wave owner bag
This time it feels like it is cooked.  The reason
why I close my eyes is that I can't see for one period of time, but
when I close my eyes and put my consciousness on my fingertips
, I get 10 eyes.
I'm saying that as 10 women, it's 10th dimension, but
if you lie
, I think it's the person who linked to that kind of talent that you originally had.
Connection with the side
Ah ah ah
I was probably
about 19 years old when I met the side I've been doing it since then
There was a big teacher who told me to go for a small amount
Well, that's right, he
taught me his technique now.
Tee tee
4th The
next process changed to the process of dying.
Even if the circle gets bigger, I can't hear any more, so I decided the four directions of the salt, and then the
four viewpoints grow, and when the four viewpoints grow, it becomes a square.
Well, it's kind of like magic, but
[Music] You
can't fold it up just because you don't really use the balance you just said
.
He disappeared when I learned for 3 years, but I learned a lot from him.
+ I
don't know if it's efficiency. I don't know. The
soba toilet made my life a big
river.  I want to glue people together in the world
[Music]
I've been doing it for 18 years now, but there is a lot of variety on the side from there, so I
think it will take a lifetime if I want to learn everything.
I'm still doing it to find it first.
[Music]
I think simple things are the best,
so the simpler the answer, the more
aesthetics it is.
I don't think it's beautiful, I think it's beautiful
[Music]
I'm making pota once a week